downtown las vegas business vandalized
with graffiti bearing a hurtful message
mary jane velez spoke to the owner who
discovered that graffiti this morning
the lily claire foundation a place for
hope and healing says this message of
hate has no place in our community
keith resnick the executive director of
the foundation found the racist graffiti
he acquired the building on gas and 9th
street a year ago making renovations as
they prepared to open it this fall to
support children with special needs this
morning i was just shocked to see this
new graffiti on the face of our building
this is the new lily claire foundation's
campus helping children living with
special needs and
their genetic birth conditions and the
families who love them and you know this
is a message of hate and we're a
foundation all about love with security
cameras outside the building resnick is
hopeful to have caught the culprit on
video and is urging downtown las vegas
businesses to keep a lookout that's why
i'm so proud of the city
it's vigilant it's caring it's
supportive of what lily claire is doing
and everyone who has seen this message
so far has been appalled resnick says
it's going to take all of us to combat
hate and says that conversation starts
with you
well this is a racist and threatening
message and i think the thing we all
need to do more of is talk to each other
understand each other learn about each
other
and come to the conclusion that we're
all just human beings
let's take care of each other on 9th
street and gas mary jane balleza live
local now